For the purposes of the Sunshine app,
this information is purely theoretical.
In fact, you'll really only need
to consider this later,
when you're adding things like Sensor
or LocationListeners.
Until then, the default components
will handle much of this behavior for you.
In any case, now that you understand
the lifecycle and the way
the system handles exiting your app,
when it needs its resources,
you should hopefully understand why Exit
or Quit buttons in Android apps
serve no practical purpose.
At most, you can call "Finish"
on an activity
and it will get torn down instantly.
That's actually exactly what happens
when the user simply hits "Back"
from within their activity.
If you're still not convinced,
check out the video
in the Instructor Notes
where I explain my reasoning
with a little more, color.